people Bobby Lee's I want to say this
Bobby Lee's sister-in-law said that I
was her least favorite guest on tiger
belly I just got a text about that from
Bobby but nope not from Bobby from from
a longtime listener of my friend of mine
goes Bobby Lee's sister-in-law the
sister of his girlfriend okay Kyla I was
at least hi you guessed when I'm really
born on there though we're not serious
no oh thanks so sometimes if you don't
have the right chemistry Kingdom no I
thought we Bobby and I always get along
but you know what [ __ ] that hurt my
feelings
did it sure did but also who cares I
know but still how dare you Kyla's her
name delight let's go Bobby who's a
straight-up dimepiece and her sisters
super hot oh great so she's hot as well
she hates me yeah great great dad join
the party
okay but the thing is is uh you know who
stopped by my house today who are you
the text going hey you home from Chris
D'Elia yo yeah he goes I'm in the
neighborhood the old really
dolia stop by the crib today dude yeah
very unlike him well he was over there
doing no Whitney Cummings podcast oh we
live like his father his father called
him up and I guess Chris had been
traveling around lucky nyata
where his mom where they live and his
mama's home and his father who's Italian
from Jersey goes hey you up in the
lock-in Jana today Chris goes yeah he
goes just driving around yes yeah I
guess what you do I don't know I'd
coffee and saw a friend he goes you did
huh in LA cañada cuz cuz yeah ding say
hi you know your mother was home right
oh wow and he goes I guess you stopped
off you say out of your mother when
you're in luck in the ahta
for sure holy [ __ ] you had a
neighborhood that one old school Italian
on me scared of yeah my mother you know
Italians are weird that way cuz my
mother on him sense is sayin my mother
like is very educated and all but one
time I told on my sister my mother
punished my sister and she punished me
for being a rat oh yeah you got it
you know me yeah Chris came over and he
met the little man he met the little D
tt was all about him ah he's so cute
tt what's he about six feet tall man 56
for okay all trapped out getting
recruited by Chicago Bears I went to
food truck diaries our boy Israel is
taller than you he's Holley big boy yeah
I send my video today because I someone
sent me a video of his car McLaren f20 s
racing at gt2 RS like real racecar
drivers and the gt2 RS one and I sent my
video when this could be us but you play
it that's good that's good
yeah about a switchblade why after
Street cuz I'm 10 after Street no I went
to a gun shop and they had these little
and they'd say you can always tell when
they're this big but I was like I want a
little no daddy knows we need the real
ones you got it on you know I was
looking forward to show you he goes yeah
oh hi seven when I was a kid yeah
they're so cool yeah have that a big boy
though they got the stilettos when they
come out through the tree
you had the real one yes think because a
good god they were cool yeah
just in case there's a situation [ __ ] -
there's nothing cooler back in the old
days the guy would have a switch break
it would be this lame mmm remember the
butterfly knife though guys oh well
those Filipino and headley filipino
through holi those dudes are the bad
[ __ ] man those guys you like
that that's what they do is trained in a
knife fighting yeah knife knives are so
unforgiving like but really you can only
train a knife fight if you're in Japan
yeah and if your be a knife fighter
attack Filipino knife I mean I go [ __ ]
is crazy be a knife fighter in Texas you
shot in the face yes you getting shot
but these dudes they do some crazy [ __ ]
yeah but also find another hobby though
you know yeah knife fighting is not good
also but say your hand to hand combat
stuff isn't gonna work but look at that
does be shot that dudes will be shot of
stab stab stare I stabbed depends on
them what the bullet looks like Hydra
Shok hollow-tip Tama I'll take a
twenty-two over a [ __ ] huge place
these dudes don't know that's it's
[ __ ] crazy oh wow look at there
yeah those guys are I think the same guy
here yay
sweet star a child oh look at his face
the dead serious yeah he's done some
[ __ ] to you oh it's three of him though
yeah he'll open yeah but if I can't
fight through a triplets triplets are
hard to fight you know and I fighting to
a dying art look at that and I say a
curved blade those don't scare me they
the squiggly ones you know the squiggly
ones I think they had a picture it on
their chin
yeah that top one nothing gives me that
yeah they're just pretty unforgiving see
you later
that thing is gonna you're gonna just
get [ __ ] it's gonna fall off yeah
you don't you don't hear a lot about
knives anymore the dining out dude well
with guns but neither not you know
carrying a knife in California carry a
knife that's large enough it's a felony
it's not a misdemeanor a gun is a
misdemeanor a nicer night when they
found it's like a sword to frontier law
anything over two inches I believe is a
felony yeah it's a felony looks like I'm
kiddin there's a dude who's a camera guy
my thing and he had a straight-up sheath
knife in a military sheath and the back
out of his belt in the back of his pants
right I was like right protection he
goes now just carry it for stuff I'll go
I don't think so that's a dagger sir
it's a dagger so you're either stabbing
people in their sleeper in their back
yeah under my bed I have this this large
knife I get from the military went to
that Marines thing they gave me this
knife for completing the mission mission
mission this big it's like one of those
like command yeah yeah it's black yeah
like stainless steel yeah the best is
going a gun shop some of those guys are
like great and some of them are just I
go what's his knife for and a guy goes
survival giant sheath knife oh my god
this is just Kanye saying he's gonna run
for president and then his reaction
after he says it which I know so it was
not joking and you'll see how he's not
joking here legit when I run for
president 2024 we were gonna definitely
know which I laughing
it was all that say I knew sliders
terrible here's the problem with Kanye
he's on this he's off his meds right has
legit mental sickness which makes him
also very creative but also there comes
pros and cons the cons would be this
[ __ ] biz also just trolling he
distraught that's what he's professional
controller to but the other thing about
him is he's so religious now have you
yes Kim and and everyone on his staff to
live celibate not to have sex yeah he's
like doing all this crazy stuff now it's
such a bummer do you think he's also
doing that kind of let roll it's it's a
weird thing it's hard to I hope I'm a
big Kanye fan of some of his stuff and
then I'll see you a lot of stuff I'm
just like oh god dude new albums trash I
think like anything else when somebody
steps out of their area of expertise
stick to music well here's the problem
they'll be is a trump one so now
everyone's like oh yeah anybody can win
that's right that's right
Trump hey here's the thing they're right
yeah but Trump's also have a businessman
who spent a lot of time in politics
being a businessman so never but never
yeah definitely not a politician
yeah not a politician he's a reality
really the biggest thing he's ever done
reality stuff yeah yeah that was and so
you get used to not okay
why not me yeah yeah yeah it's crazy i I
do think that Trump had more experience
with trade and with China and dealing
with this there's a difference there he
comes at it from a but you know look
Kanye West is a businessman too isn't he
you know he's worth billion dollars
worth a billion dollars
close to it he's rich man in music now
just I think he surpassed jay-z and or
he's on pace of hata
jay-z and trash I don't like it cause
it's so religious I don't
yeah he is a very unique I I would I
think the people running for president
when you had suffered mental illness and
when you're that unstable is pretty
scary
I think trials for the unstable to
though I would say comes in our cities
are Trump's consistent in that you you
can kind of predict what he's gonna do
if you attack him you know right back
again this is just rolling from Connie
yeah a cube nine it would never in a
million years of wind right be that you
thought the amount of stress and what
comes with being the president he's no
fun you think you'll be able to do this
music can do this stuff be president you
have any idea what the entails you know
the exhaustion and the stretch but on
your family the life is over now this
jet sent me already talking about any
president but there is ego there right
so if he becomes president just a little
yeah the ego you're feeding the ego
I'm a doctor Trump who has the biggest
of you in the world he buddy do not do
this awful you mentioned theof one and
three Studios ago I created the guest of
the year that was my idea
I said I'm the guest of the year yeah
well it's my idea no don't make me look
up the tape I said I am the guest of the
year against the ever how much you want
to bet you mother's all right but you
might have said I'm the guest no I I
started the whole guest of the Year
thing no one was talking about the guest
of the year on this show because at the
time it was clear-cut Rappaport is the
very best [ __ ] thing that's ever
happened to Terry on carry on so then
like a year I think maybe Theo came in
with his belt he smelled like [ __ ]
fish spraying body oil and lube and
anything I'm shooting people like oh he
should be the guest here and then I
think they were maybe saying D'Elia
should be Greg guessing that's good
there was another person Lobby Lee's
very good these guys are cruel none of
them are as good a guest of the air this
is the best fighter in the kid podcast
of a person that we know when you get
like a guest like Dana Carvey or one of
these guys that day then you could
that's an outsider but as a recurring
guest cuz you notice I didn't come on I
was like I'm gonna wait till the end of
the year I'm gonna let all the [ __ ]
smoke clear you could have all people
you want [ __ ]
the red rocket daliyah you can Bobby Lee
come on and rial em in ilysm and then I
say I'm gonna wait till November I'm
gonna do my thing and they clean up
clean up clean up shut it the [ __ ] down
and you could have a feel for this non
sequitur southern [ __ ] southern charm
[ __ ] I like it with the mullet oh
yeah I don't have a mod the same haircut
since 99 1998 well-documented 89 it's
well documented so so win it so instead
of saying oh who's the guest of the year
I'm gonna I want to say this
it's the fighter the fighter in the kid
Michael Rapaport award so you can give
it we just call it the michael rapport
or all right but it's the fighter in the
kid michael rapper we'll just michael
rapaport guest of the year award
there it is could be that there's really
nobody that you can get I don't give a
[ __ ] what hot sweet dick comedian that
comes on here talking anything the guest
of the year who do you have on your on
your show I don't need no game please do
not go solo on that I just ramp solo on
this down so low on that on that ass
solo another 45 55 minutes a good of
pure fire of sugar [ __ ] good [ __ ]
sugar [ __ ] 50 minutes of pure [ __ ]